From the man who created some of your fondest
childhood memories, then took a huge dump
on them
Comes the prequel sequel that proved Phantom
Menace wasn’t an accident.
"This isn't how it's supposed to be."
Episode II: Attack of the Clones.
Once again the republic is in turmoil.
Watch as the chin-stroking Jedi are pulled
into a war between a completely disposable
droid army and a completely disposable clone
army.
Seriously, there is no reason to get emotionally
involved in any of this crap.
Experience an awkward, forced love story as
soulless as the computer it was made in
With so many visual effects, the filmmakers
didn’t have any time left over for things
like
realistic choreography
realistic dialogue
"I'm haunted by the kiss that you should never
have given me."
Or realistic Hayden Christensen acting.
"I don't like sand: it's coarse and rough
and irritating and it gets everywhere.
Not like here."
C'mon, JJ, there's no way you can do any worse
than this.
Natalie Portman and her space hair return
as Senator Padme Amidala.
When two of the galaxy’s best sharpshooting
assassins try to kill her with a poisonous
worm pooping robot,
two Jedi warriors will come to her aid:
Obi Wan Kenobi, a man forced to act opposite
lifeless CGI characters like Hayden Christenson...
and Anakin Skywalker,
a rat-tailed a**hole who’s been creepily
stalking Padme for the last decade.
"I’ve thought about her every day since
we parted.”
"I don’t think she liked me watching her.”
"I'd much rather dream about Padme."
"You're exactly the way I remember you in
my dreams."
"Please don't look at me like that."
"Why not?"
"It makes me feel uncomfortable."
"Sorry, m'lady."
Ugh.
Ride along with these one-dimensional heroes
in a movie so unevenly paced, you’ll have
to wait over an hour before you even meet
the main villain.
Instead, strap yourself in for even more of
the stuff that made Phantom Menace so cold,
lifeless,
and boring, like...
People sitting and talking,
Standing and talking,
Walking and talking,
One person standing and talking while another
is sitting and talking,
People standing and talking then taking a
seat for more talking,
And
a whole bunch of wipes.
Starring...
Haydon’t Act Again
Ewan A Bad Movie
Yogurt
M. Bison
Nipply Portman
Lawrence Fishburn
Definitely Not the Emperor
Dickhead
Cthulhu
Darth Saruman
and Jango Unbrained
Star Wars Episode 11: Attack of the Clones.
Correct me if I’m wrong here but the clones
never attack anyone in this movie.
So why the f*** would you call this movie
Attack of the Clones?!
Be sure to subscribe for more Honest Trailers.